Varilux lenses by Essilor.
♪
LAWRENCE: WELCOME BACK THE SAME
DAY DHS SECRETARY MAYORKAS
CONFIDENTIALLY TOUTED THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S SO-CALLED
PROGRESS ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
HE SHARED A MUCH DIFFERENT
MESSAGE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
LISTEN TO THIS LEAKED AUDIO.
AUDIO OBTAINED BY FOX.
LAWRENCE JOINING ME NOW KEN
CUCCINELLI THE FORMER ACTING
SECRETARY FOR DHS.
WERE YOU SURPRISED SECRETARY
WHEN YOU HEARD THIS AUDIO?
>> YEAH.
I WAS SURPRISED.
SADLY I WAS SURPRISED BECAUSE
IT’S THE FIRST HONEST ACCURATE
STATEMENT I HAVE HEARD OUT OF
SECRETARY MAYORKAS SINCE HE WAS
SWORN IN ABOUT THE BORDER.
LAWRENCE: BUT I’M NOT SURE I
BELIEVE HIM.
LOOK, THIS IS A GUY WHO WILL PAP
DER TO THE FOLKS IN FRONT OF HIM
AND REMEMBER WHO HE WAS TALKING
TO.
HE WAS TALKING TO THE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS THAT PROTECT YOU
AND ME IN THIS COUNTRY AND
HONESTLY, HE HAS NEVER CARED
ABOUT THEM.
THAT GOES BACK TO HIS LAST TIME
OF SERVICE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY WHEN HE
FAMOUSLY SAID, YOU KNOW, THE
MORALE OF THESE CBP OFFICERS IS
OF NO MOMENT TO ME.
HE DIDN’T CARE THEN.
HE DOESN’T CARE NOW.
BUT HE IS TALKING TO THEM AND
ACTIONS WILL SPEAK LOUDER THAN
THESE WORDS.
SO, IS HE GOING TO FOLLOW
THROUGH AND ACTUALLY MAKE
CHANGES NEEDED TO PUSH THESE
NUMBERS DOWN AND TO TAKE THE
STRAIN OFF THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS WHO ARE JUST GETTING, YOU
KNOW, DEL DEL DEL DEL LUGED.
SAID A THOUSAND A DAY A CRISIS.
WE ARE 7,000 AND COUNTING.
LITERALLY THE WORST LOGISTICAL
BURDEN AT OUR BORDER IN HISTORY.
IN HISTORY, EVER.
LAWRENCE: YOU KNOW,
MR. SECRETARY, THE NUMBERS DON’T
LIE.
IN JULY NEW NUMBERS.
212,000.
THAT’S UP 13% FROM JUNE.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
IT’S LIKE -- THINK OF IT THIS
WAY, WE JUST FINISHED THE
OLYMPICS.
IT’S LIKE MICHAEL PHELPS BREAK
50-METER RECORD BY 2 SECONDS.
YOU KNOW IT’S AN EXPLOSION.
IT’S AN ABSOLUTE EXPLOSION THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN BUILDING IT UP.
LAWRENCE: WHAT’S THE END GAME
HERE?
>> THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
YOU HAVE HIT IT ON THE HEAD.
THERE ISN’T AN EXIT STRATEGY
HERE.
THEY HAVE -- THEY TOLD THEIR
BASE OH, OPEN BORDERS, WE’RE
GOING TO OPEN THE DOOR, IT WILL
BE GREAT.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THESE PEOPLE
REGISTERED TO VOTE EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE ILLEGAL ALIENS AND CAN
YOU LOOK AT THEIR VOTING BILLS
ON CAPITOL HILL AND SEE THAT’S
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO.
HOWEVER, BECAUSE THIS IS TRULY
UNSUSTAINABLE IN THE REAL WORLD,
SOMETHING WE TOLD THEM OVER AND
OVER AND OVER.
FRANKLY, YOU JUST HAD A FEDERAL
COURT ORDER THEM TO RESTART THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO PROGRAM.
AND PART OF WHAT THEY CITED, THE
JUDGE CITED THERE WAS MARK
MORGAN’S TESTIMONY ABOUT HOW IN
THE TRANSITION FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IN OVER 100
MEETINGS WITH PROFESSIONALS, NOT
THE POLITICAL FOLKS, THE
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORK THE
BORDER, THEY WERE TOLD OVER AND
OVER THAT EXACTLY WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING HAPPEN IS EXACTLY WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
AND THEY PRESSED AHEAD ANYWAY
AND NOW THEY HAVE BACKED
THEMSELVES INTO A POLITICAL
CORNER THAT IS COSTING AMERICA
SECURITY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
LAWRENCE: MR. SECRETARY, WE KNOW
YOU GUYS BRIEFED THEM.
WE KNOW THE STATE DEPARTMENT
BRIEFED THEM.
THEN YOU HAVE GOT TO ASK
YOURSELF THE QUESTION WAS THIS
BOY DESIGN?
I THINK WE KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THIS.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE GOT A
PROGRESSIVE LEFT THAT HAS A
POLICY OF OPEN BORDERS, THEY
DON’T BELIEVE ANYBODY IS, IN
FACT, ILLEGAL.
THEY DON’T BELIEVE IN THE LEGAL
CHANNELS THAT YOU SHOULD --
DISRESPECTING THE CURRENT
IMMIGRANT THAT ARE HERE AND THEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE CUBAN PEOPLE
THAT ARE FIGHTING IN THEIR OWN
COUNTRY.
>> ISN’T THAT UNBELIEVABLE.
>> JUST INCREDIBLE.
YOU KNOW, THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY, WE HAVE BEEN JUST A
BEACON OF LIGHT FOR THOSE KINDS
OF OPPRESSED FOLKS.
AND NOT DISRESPECTING EVEN
ILLEGAL ALIENS WHO ARE COMING ON
AN INDIVIDUAL BASIS.
BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT THEY’RE
COMING FROM.
RIGHT?
THEY ARE NOT FIGHTING EVIL AND
TYRANNY AND OPPRESSION ALTHOUGH
SOMETIMES I THINK WE ARE HERE.
SO, BUT IT IS INCREDIBLE
DICHOTOMY.
IT IS A TERRIBLE POLICY BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
IT’S DOING TERRIBLE HARM TO
AMERICA.
ESPECIALLY OUR POOR PEOPLE.
LAWRENCE: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SEE IT THAT’S WHY THEY’RE